dr wall it just seems like every week i
pick up a newspaper and i see about our
young athletes
having problems with their bodies
falling apart
like cardiomyopathy and challenges like
that what can we give
our athletes and our children so that
they can be healthy and have long lives
that we want as well
that's a great question because most
people believe that exercise is good for
you
and that was always a great question you
know is exercise good for you is it
necessary for health and longevity
and when you inspect this question you
have to look at professional athletes
who
spend most of their teenage years and
going through university in the semi
pros and the pros
uh training and practicing and doing
their events and if exercise was
the factor in living a long helpful life
athletes should live longer than couch
potatoes but when you look at this
critically couch potatoes in america
live to be 75.5
and the average athlete depending on the
sport and their level of competence
lived to be 62 to 68 far short of what a
a couch potato uh lives to be and of
course athletes suffer from a great many
joint diseases and bone injuries and
tendons and ligaments
back necks shoulders ankles knees and
hips
and have to suffer through an enormous
amount of surgeries to deal with this
and athletes develop some 800 different
diseases
and what is it why is it that athletes
don't fare as well
as the the couch potato was simply
because
athletes sweat more in five years than
couch potatoes do in 75 years
and when you sweat you're not just
sweating out gatorade you're sweating
out all
60 essential minerals and they're called
essential minerals because if they're
missing for any length of time you get
some horrible degenerative disease many
of which are life-threatening
so you don't have to be a rocket
scientist to figure out who's more
likely
to be debilitated or even die of these
these life-threatening diseases
an athlete who sweats out quarts of
sweat during an event or training or
practice
or a couch potato who's laying on a
couch in an air-conditioned dens
switching the channels yelling honey
bring in the popcorn i'm changing the
channels
and this is very serious because the
center for disease control
says that as many as a hundred thousand
young athletes under the age of thirty
a hundred thousand each year die
suddenly during
an event or training or exercise or
immediately after an event
from cardiomyopathy heart disease which
you mentioned and
ruptured aneurysm and we know that
cardiomyopathy heart disease is due to a
selenium deficiency
and ruptured aneurysms is due to a
copper deficiency so you can begin to
put two and two together why does a 10
year old die
of a ruptured aneurysm well you sweat
out all of this copper
and you can't get copper from curly
french fries and pepsis yes it doesn't
work
dr wallach you talked about the effects
of pollution
in your studies how about the pollution
that we're getting
is this going to help us out any i we
have problems with pollution as a human
being
is our body will store toxic chemicals
both the organic chemicals like ddt
and the minerals that are toxic like
lead mercury and cadmium
stores in our fat in our body and our
liver which is the big filter in our
body kind of filters the blood
and for our body to get rid of these
toxins for our bodies to
actually process them so we can get them
out and not store them in our body
we require an enormous amount of
vitamins and trace minerals to pull this
off we need antioxidants
to protect us at the cellular level
which is the granddaddy of of course
is selenium the trace middle selenium
and then there's calcium
and you have zinc and you have magnesium
and you have vitamin c
and vitamin e and beta-carotene and
vitamin a and you have the
pycnogenols the grapeseed extracts and
you have
things like the green tea these will all
help protect you
from specific toxins at the cellular
level
and even selenium alone will help you
dump or get rid of
toxic metals like mercury and
excessive amounts of arsenic calcium
will be a great almost specific antidote
for lead poisoning
and then you have all 90 essential
nutrients which will help your liver
process
any stored organo chemical any of the
ddts and pcbs and
agricultural chemicals and industrial
waste that might get in your fat
and your your liver your body will get
rid of these if it's healthier
and is able to do all the chemical
processes that we need to do to
to pass these toxins out of our body dr
wallach what about
arthritis well arthritis is my favorite
disease because it's easy to fix
it's one of the great myths that the
medical profession
perpetuates is that you can't build bone
mass after the age of 50 60
70 years of age you can only slow down
the loss and the reason why they say
that
is because they try to rebuild bone mass
using
plain calcium whether it's tums or
calcium citrate or carbonate or
gluconator
or lactate and your body will not retain
much or any of the calcium you
supplement with in your bones
without first building new bone matrix
you have to have new bone matrix this is
this
this rubbery collagen material that
looks like tendon or skin
and it makes up 25 to 40 percent of our
bone weight
40 percent when you're a child and 25
percent when you're an adult
and so it's absolutely essential if you
want to deal with
with the wear and tear arthritis
osteoarthritis degenerative arthritis
ankylosing spondylitis effectively you
have to take all 90 essential nutrients
and the best way to do that is with dr
wallach's formula
remember i'm a veterinarian as well as a
physician and we learned a long time ago
maybe a hundred years ago
in veterinary medicine that we could
actually prevent and reverse maybe even
use the cure word and animals
arthritis simply by giving the animal
the raw material
to develop properly and to maintain and
repair the joints
and so using this information that we
developed in animals if you use the same
concept for human beings
i have literally seen tens of thousands
of people over the years
who had boned bone arthritis they had
osteoarthritis they have
degenerative arthritis ankylosing
spondylitis which are basically a
joint form of osteoporosis the joint
ends of the bones
and they've tried all kinds of
medication and of course if you take
medication if you take a painkiller
you take an anti-inflammatory for
arthritis essentially all you're doing
is cutting the wire the red warning
light pain in a joint says don't use me
until you fix me and by taking a
painkiller by taking a anti-inflammatory
which will reduce pain
you're allowing that joint to be used
even though it would have been painful
without the drug and so you're wearing
that joint out faster and faster and
faster
and to me it's criminally negligent for
someone to
be prescribed a painkiller or an
anti-inflammatory for joint disease
without repairing the joint at the same
time and this is where the formula
really shines and works just like a
charm in human beings
so does the same apply for bone spurs
absolutely bone spurs are a
manifestation
of osteoporosis a person will get bone
spurs and calcium deposits
when you have osteoporosis just the
opposite of what a doctor will tell you
and you need more calcium more magnesium
you need the bone matrix
you need the collagen the glucosamine
sulfate the chondroitin sulfate
and those bone spurs and the calcium
deposits will actually
re-architecture back down to a normal
bone takes a little while takes
four to six months to pull that off but
you can do it on a regular basis
absolutely
cancer seems to be striking everywhere
in our
population these days it seems like a
majority of the people
in their senior lives die of cancer what
in the
pig arthritis formula or the american
longevity products that we have that we
can help people that are
facing the challenge of cancer that's a
great question
back at the turn of the century 1895
one out of 10 americans developed cancer
right now
it's three out of five and by the year
2050 is projected
two out of three people are going to
develop cancer in america
the onset of cancer appears to be
directly related to the amount of
of carcinogens these are toxic waste
either from agriculture
or from the industrial waste that we
find in our air and our food and our
water and in the dust
around us and the lack of
the ability to defend to defend against
these
these carcinogens and the most common
defense mechanism that we have
the one that we have access to in a very
economical way are the antioxidants like
selenium
like the grapeseed extract like the
green tea
you're looking at vitamin e vitamin c
beta carotene
and avoiding fried foods and margins and
and things we have control of eating as
much organically grown food as possible
and according to the medical school at
the
university of arizona this came out in
jama the journal of american medical
association
december 25th 1996 i mean we're talking
about
a great christmas gift to the american
people
they did a wonderful study 10 years it
was a double blind study 300 people
they gave the study group 250 micrograms
which is one quarter of one milligram
and we're talking an
itsy bitsy amount of selenium they just
used selenium alone didn't change
anything else
and by giving these people 250
micrograms one quarter of a milligram of
the trace mineral selenium
they were able to reduce the risk of
esophageal cancer by 71 percent
prostate cancer by 69 greater than two
thirds
colon and rectal cancer by 64 almost
two-thirds
lung cancer was reduced by 48 percent
whether you smoked or not
and in a parallel study from the
university of california san diego
250 micrograms one quarter of one
milligram
of selenium the trace mineral saline
reduced the risk of breast cancer by
50 to 80 percent and the same study
showed that if you already have cancer
if you take 250 micrograms of selenium
every day
you will in fact double the natural
history life expectancy of a particular
type of cancer
for instance lung cancer the natural
history is about a year brain cancer is
less than a year
uterine ovarian colon
breast cancer is two to five years
prostate cancer is five to eight years
well just by taking 250 micrograms
of the trace mineral selenium every day
one quarter of one milligram according
to the university of
arizona's medical school you can double
that life expectancy just by doing that
one thing and so if you take the other
antioxidants and give up margins and
fried foods and sugar and caffeine
and avoid as many of the agricultural
waste and the toxic waste from the
industry that you can
you will be able to avoid an enormous
amount of cancer and if you already have
cancer
doing other things such as taking sharp
cartilage and the antioxidants and
getting on macrobiotic diets and
and so forth uh you can add many
healthful years to your life you can
certainly have a better quality of life
and many people will extend their lives
in a great way 10
20 30 40 years and obviously there's no
way you can look in somebody's eyes and
say you're the one that's going to live
50 years and so people just have to do
all the right things
and they're going to get the best that
can be gotten from nutrition
and the supplements dr wallick i've been
a diabetic for about 30 years
what can what kind of minerals should i
take to help me okay well first of all
are you
an adult onset type 2 diabetic or a
juvenile onset type 1 diabetic
juvenile onset type one okay
well you are insulin dependent because
the definition of a juvenile onset type
one diabetic is that you do not make any
insulin
and so you will never be able to wean
off of insulin you will always have to
take some insulin
but there are two trace minerals
chromium and vanadium that will make the
insulin that you supplement yourself
with
very efficient and most people who are
juvenile onset type 1 diabetics
are able to reduce the amount of insulin
they require to stabilize their blood
sugar
uh by supplementing with the chromium
and vanadium and of course american
longevity has two great sources
the plant-derived colloidal chromium and
vanadium and the chelated chromium
vanadium in the
ultimate sweet ease and normally a
person
learns how to adjust their insulin by
taking their blood sugar once or twice
or three times a day
and so you're taught how to adjust your
insulin intake
and just by following what you've been
taught as you supplement with is
plant derived chromium and vanadium you
will be able to get down to a new dosage
of your insulin and the value of taking
the formula plus the
ultimate sweet ease is that
there's nothing worse than paying
attention to your blood sugar levels
your insulin intake
and then dying of a ruptured aneurysm
because you didn't supplement with
copper
or developing cancer because you didn't
supplement with selenium
so it's very important even though
you're a diabetic and that is your
primary immediate concern
still over the long haul of being a
health conscious person
just out of necessity you're going to
have to supplement with all 90 essential
nutrients
even though you're a juvenile onset type
1 diabetic
you have every honest expectation of
living to be 100
symptom-free if you do everything right
what about kidneys
do you have anything that i should add
to it for my kidneys because i have
kidney problems okay well if a person
has kidney problems whether
they're a diabetic or not one of the
symptoms of kidney disease
is you'll lose a lot of protein in your
urine and that's one of the diagnostic
things
that alerts the doctor that you have a
kidney problem when they do a urine
dipstick test you have a lot
of of a protein in urine so what you
want to do in your dietary practices
is number one make sure you're consuming
a high quality protein
because you're going to be losing
protein through your
urine and of course doctors are a little
bit wacky
they say cut back on protein so we don't
get protein in your urine well
you don't want to cut back on protein
because your immune system requires
protein
to repair yourself to maintain your
kidneys your liver your muscles your
heart
every tissue in your body you need to
have a great high quality source of
protein coming in every day
and so instead of restricting protein
you want to take a high quality protein
that's biologically available and egg
protein
is the benchmark by which all other
proteins are measured and so egg protein
poached soft boiled soft scrambled and
butter in a low temperature
not fried and not cooked in margin is a
great way to
take care of your kidneys plus taking
all the essential nutrients if you do
that
you have the best chance of stabilizing
your kidneys maybe not
losing any more kidney function
sometimes you'll regain a percentage of
kidney function yes my question's on
alzheimer's
why is it more prevalent today that than
it was 15 20 years ago
well actually alzheimer's disease was a
disease that did not exist 40 years ago
alzheimer's disease even by another name
could not be found in any medical
dictionary or textbook or taught in any
medical curriculum it only became an
entity in
the medical literature in 1979 and today
it's apparently the number four killer
of adults united states over the age of
65 behind
cardiovascular disease cancer diabetes
and then comes alzheimer's disease
and it appears to me with
no doubt that is due to what i call a
physician-caused disease because doctors
have
have encouraged people in fact demanded
that people give up saturated fat and
cholesterol and move towards
a cholesterol restricted or even a free
diet to get their blood cholesterol
down below 200 and they have created no
less than
25 of these cholesterol deficiency
diseases and to me alzheimer's disease
is one of the big ones
75 percent of our brain weight is pure
cholesterol it's called myelin it's this
fatty stuff
that insulates each nerve fiber the
brain and spinal cord
and we can only make about 10 percent of
our daily need of cholesterol
the other 90 must come from the diet and
if a person
is very very good at giving up chicken
skin and red meat
and dairy and eggs like a doctor would
have them do after about six or eight or
ten years they're not going to be able
to keep up with the maintenance and
repair needs
of the cholesterol for the myelin in the
brain and spinal cord and so you can
just
expect that the person is going to
develop one or more of these 25
physician
cause diseases including acquired
seizure disorders and alzheimer's
disease
now the best way to avoid alzheimer's
disease is to eat a couple of eggs every
morning for breakfast
not cooked in margin or fried uh you
want to consume
as much as 72 ounces of red meat every
month i know this sounds like a lot but
it's just a quarter pounder a day
and you want to supplement with all the
essential nutrients
and when you get to the the vitamin e
level you want to have
at least 2 000 international units of
vitamin e
and you want 500 micrograms of selenium
and if you do that even if you already
have alzheimer's disease you can expect
you can honestly expect to have a
significant amount of return of memory
great study done by the university of
california san diego and the salk
institute
that says by taking 2 000 international
units of vitamin e alone
even if you have advanced alzheimer's
disease you can get a significant amount
of memory return
so there's hope for you great yes my um
my doctor said that my cartilage
i'm a construction worker and i hurt my
back
he said that my cartilage damage is
permanent is there anything that can be
done
well first of all how old are you i'm 28
years old
and what do you normally take for fluid
replacement when you're working out in
construction what do you drink during
the day
uh water gatorade you don't drink any
soft drinks uh yes i do okay because
normally construction workers drink a
couple of liters of pepsi a day right
yeah i could probably put down a liter
and the reason why i asked that
is because caffeine from soft drinks the
phosphates and soft drinks the sugar and
soft drinks
the caffeine in iced tea hot tea coffees
will in fact interfere with the
retention of minerals in your bones
and did you take any vitamins or
minerals that we were working in
construction
um just recently started taking it when
you were in construction prior to the
back problems yeah a lot of construction
workers will tell me well doc if it
ain't the pepsi i don't get it
right and so uh you're a perfect
candidate for the frontline
plus the efa and give up the bad things
give up
the soft drinks and the iced tea and the
lemonades and
and give up the fried foods and the
margarines
and uh i can just tell you with your age
you can honestly expect to see some
really
recognizable results in a very very
short time 60 to 90 days
and it doesn't matter what the doctor
said
if you do the right things get rid of
the bad stuff take all the essential
nutrients
making sure you get that collagen and
the glucosamine sulfate and the
chondroitin sulfate
you will repair your vertebrae you will
repair the cartilage and will repair the
disc
well thank you i've remodeled homes now
for probably 18 years and during that
time
remodeling homes for families
you notice these little children
bouncing off of walls
and what they get for breakfast and
a snack after breakfast and then lunch
again normally has
sugar in it now is this is there any uh
correlation here with add
absolutely back the turn of the century
1895 to 1900 americans are eating half a
pound of sugar per person per year
today it's 150 pounds of sugar per
person per year and somebody out there
is eating 300 pounds because
i don't eat any and i can tell you that
there's a direct correlation
between the increase in add adhd
depression
magnetic depression bipolar disease and
the increased consumption
of sugar and if you look at it there's
five million american children
school-aged children
who are on ritalin and prozac and
mipramine and other anti-depressants
in school five million drugged american
kids in in the preschool
and elementary school simply because
these kids are sensitive to sugar
like many people are sensitive to
alcohol there's good alcoholics who just
kind of go to sleep when they have a
couple of drinks
uh there's the people who get boisterous
and sing loud irish songs when they take
a couple of drinks
and there's some people who get violent
and
and very angry and become dangerous to
themselves and other people
child abuse spouse abuse they abuse
their neighbors road rage
is another way of looking at this life
threatening situations
people actually will gain criminal
behavior sometimes because alcohol acts
like a drug in them
same way with sugar some people when
they take in sugar they have low blood
sugar and they just get drowsy and fall
asleep
some people when they take in sugar they
get hyperactive and boisterous
and actually add
adhd and then there's some people when
they take in sugar again will have road
rage
uh they're very very um aggressive and
reactive and could be dangerous to
themselves and their families and other
people in the community
and to me it's criminal for coca-cola
machines and and candy machines in
school
and then wonder why kids beat up on each
other shoot each other
well in addition to getting all the
sugar out of their life from sugar
frosted flakes and pepsis and
reese's peanut butter cups and candy and
and pop tarts and syrup on their eggos
and things like
ice cream and so forth they have to
supplement with all 90 essential
nutrients even little kids from the
moment they're born
to develop properly this includes their
emotions and repair and maintain
themselves and especially
lithium chromium and vanadium and
there's an enormous amount of research
in human beings
which show that lithium deficiency
results in
hyperactivity add adhd depression manic
depression
and criminal behavior and so they have
to do both again
a teaspoon for 20 pounds of body weight
for kids under the
weight of 100 pounds and no sugar
whatsoever
in any source and you can avoid all this
uh
it's amazing just within days they will
be perfectly normal little kids
i have a son that has grandma's seizures
can you recommend anything for that
okay well first of all uh was your son
born with these grand mal seizures did
he fire them later in life
no he was born with it he has
hydrocephalus okay
cerebral palsy okay well first of all
cerebral palsy
and hydrocephalus are what's called a
congenital birth defect these are caused
by nutritional deficiencies during
pregnancy
they can be a zinc deficiency vitamin a
deficiency copper deficiency
obviously has two problems there and
it's not unusual because a deficiency
even of a single nutrient can cause as
many as 10
different diseases so your son
unfortunately has a very common
series of events here and because the
epilepsy or the seizure disorder is
associated with these two congenital
birth defects
the odds are the nutrition alone will
not put the genie back in the bottle
and he may have to stay on a seizure
anti-seizure medication such as dilantin
or phenobar forever however
the thing that you have to be concerned
with is almost all of these
anti-seizure medications have a downside
in that they deplete their bones and
minerals
it's not unusual for a six year old or a
ten-year-old or teenager to get
arthritis and osteoporosis and noisy
joints and
twitches and cramps and loose teeth and
receding gums and back problems and
all the things are associated with
mineral deficiencies so your child is a
perfect candidate for the formula
simply because he's on dilantin or
on another seizure um anti-seizure
medication very important
and uh does he weigh less than 100
pounds yes he does okay then i'd give
him a teaspoon for 20 pounds of body
weight he weighs 40 pounds you give him
two teaspoons twice a day
he weighs 60 pounds three teaspoons or a
tablespoon twice a day
and if they weigh 10 pounds you give him
a half a teaspoon so it depends on you
know what weight
category falls into okay and again
there's no reason
why he can't live to be a hundred and
usually
uh these youngsters with these types of
congenital birth defects die
of of some nutritional deficiency
disease
and so by giving them all essential
nutrients you will extend his life
enormously
and it won't hurt him in any way i love
that question
no absolutely not won't hurt him okay
thank you you're very welcome
dr wallach my mother is going through
menopause right now is there anything
that you can recommend for her
sure number one the standard approach
for menopause
standard medical approach is with
hormone replacement therapy
estrogen or estrogen with progesterone
which is the premarin
and the false assumption is
that it will reduce your risk of heart
disease or reduce your risk of
osteoporosis
and eliminate the more common symptoms
of menopause which include of course
night sweats and
and hot flashes and things of this
nature and certainly estrogen will do
that
uh take care of the hot flashes and the
night sweats
but long-term studies show that a person
a woman is not going to retain any more
bone mass by using estrogen or premarine
with
progesterone than taking a sugar pill
after a seven or ten year period there's
just no difference between the two
groups of women
also in a very recent study they show if
a woman's already had heart disease of
any kind or another
and she takes hormone replacement
therapy it actually increases her risk
of heart disease by 50 percent
to take estrogen supplements there's
been an enormous amount of research in
scandinavia which shows that
women who take a supplemental estrogen
or estrogen
with premarin with progesterone
actually increase their risk of breast
and uterine cancer by 78
and so to me there is no amount of
benefit from
estrogen supplement to justified in fact
your own adrenal glands
and liver can manufacture more than
enough estrogen to avoid the typical
symptoms of night sweats and
and so forth uh just simply by taking in
the raw materials
95 percent of the weight of estrogen is
cholesterol
and to convert that cholesterol into
estrogen you need all essential
nutrients for your adrenal glands and
liver to function properly
so again the two eggs every morning for
breakfast poached
soft boiled soft scrambling butter low
temperatures not cooked in margarine not
fried
the formula plus the ultimate efa would
give all 90 essential nutrients
and women who have had menopausal
symptoms for
five years women who have been on
estrogen supplements
women who have had pms for many years
for that matter
will actually get an enormous amount of
benefit and we've seen
literally thousands of them whose
marriages have actually been saved
because these
these premenstrual symptoms and also the
post-menopausal symptoms
are just totally go away okay my next
question is my husband and i are
thinking about
starting a family and we want to know
the nutritional way to go
okay that's a great question people
always ask me when when do children need
to start taking vitamins and minerals
and the answer is when they're still an
egg is when you want to start them and
so
we've learned in the animal industry and
remember i'm a veterinarian as well as a
physician
we've learned in the animal industry
that we could prevent as much as 98
of all birth defects even ones that are
thought to be genetic in humans
simply by giving the females especially
the females
all known essential nutrients for that
species six months prior to conception
build up that female animal's body and
stores of these
essential nutrients so the embryo
implants in the uterine wall and
develops in an environment that has
optimal amounts guaranteed optimal
amounts of all the nutrients
and you will almost eliminate the
possibility of a congenital birth defect
related to a mineral or vitamin or amino
acid or essential fatty acid deficiency
to give you some idea of how successful
this is according to the university of
california san francisco right now in
america
one out of every 33 human babies in
america are born with some
physical or emotional or mental birth
defect one out of 33.
in animals it's only one out of five
hundred thousand if they're
fed these commercial diets that have all
the known nutrients in them
and so it's just very very easy to
understand well if we supplement
young women and men who are in the
childbearing years with these
nutrients that will be able to eliminate
totally eliminate cleft
palates cleft lip spina bifida eye
defects heart defects
hernias of various types club feet no
feet
web fingers and toes no fingers and toes
muscular dystrophy down syndrome
cerebral palsy cystic fibrosis these are
all preventable with proper
preconception nutrition so the earlier
that a couple who wants to have normal
healthy children have a wonderful
uncomplicated pregnancy the earlier you
can get on all the essential nutrients
prior to conception
the better off everybody is okay um
one more question if you know you have a
dominant gene in your body for muscular
dystrophy
and you the you know the mother has it
is there any way that you know you won't
pass it on through
to your children through minerals and
vitamins before you get pregnant
okay that's a good question because
there's this this um
false belief in the medical profession
that muscular dystrophy is due to a
dominant gene
to genetics genetically transmitted as
we've learned in the animal industry
that's not true and you can understand
why we're so excited in the animal
industry we eliminated muscular
dystrophy in animals back in the 1950s
and nobody knows more about muscle
physiology
muscle health and muscle disease than
veterinarians because
what what is muscle is meat and we know
more about growing healthy meat than
anybody else in the world as
veterinarians
and so we eliminated muscular dystrophy
in all its farms
from animals because a farmer could not
stay in business economically
if they had lambs and calves and pigs
and chickens and turkeys
being born or hatched with muscular
dystrophy it would just not be a
profitable industry
so by eliminating muscular dystrophy and
fibromyalgia and all the diseases
that afflict muscles we were able to
make the agricultural industry a
profitable industry and keep the cost of
animal products such as
meat and dairy and poultry and eggs down
to where the average american could
afford to eat them every day
and by using these same nutritional
principles giving the muscles
all the essential nutrients during
pregnancy and also immediately after
birth
the odds of having a child with muscular
dystrophy is is
reduced almost zero and so i wouldn't be
too excited about the the pronouncement
that you have a genetic disease
just probably not so
okay thank you hello dr wallach the
women in my family
are plagued with hay fever and asthma
and allergies and every summer i have to
listen
to them nattering on about all their
symptoms and the latest drug that they
got from their doctor
and i don't want to join those ranks is
there a better way
absolutely let's start with asthma it's
the easiest one to deal with
asthma is actually a deficiency of three
nutrients magnesium manganese and the
essential fatty acids
and by taking the formula twice a day
you're going to get the
optimal amounts of the plant derived
colloidal and the chelated
magnesium and manganese and then by
taking the minimum daily requirement
the nine grams of the essential fatty
acids that would be
three of the ultimate efa capsules with
each meal nine a day
that's going to give you the minimum
daily requirement of the essential fatty
acids
and those three nutrients together the
magnesium manganese the essential fatty
acids
will allow you to produce what's called
prostaglandins prostaglandins are little
short-lived hormones that last in your
bloodstream
30 seconds 60 seconds and your body is
continuously making them kind of rapid
fire
and when you don't have those three
nutrients you cannot make the proper
prostaglandins to keep your bronchi
and your trachea open and that's when
you develop asthma and
it's very common when people take all 90
essential nutrients including the
magnesium and manganese the essential
fatty acids within weeks or months
the tightness this constant tightness in
their chest is significantly reduced or
maybe even totally relieved
the frequency and the severity of their
asthma attacks significantly
is reduced i would certainly still keep
an inhaler available until she
you know in case you have some um
unexpected emergency kind of like
wearing your seat belt
even though you're on a smooth flight
you you're not going to uh
anticipate sudden turbulence you need to
be prepared for emergencies
but um you have very honest expectation
of doing very well
then as far as inhalant allergies from
dust and pollens and
seasonal ones from dust and pounds and
maybe constant ones from danders and
cats and dogs and
chickens and feathers and your pillows
that kind of thing
maybe even chemicals that come out of
rugs and formica and new cars like
formaldehyde and
other chemicals you want to
get your immune system working optimally
so it can protect you from these things
because most people are able to
tolerate them and what happens is when
your immune system doesn't have enough
nutrition to function optimally
you become a victim of these things
assaulting you all the time
and so what you want to do is number one
take all the ascension nutrients so
your immune system which includes your
liver and your spleen
your tonsils and your appendix your
thymus
your white blood cells which include
the neutrophils and the lymphocytes and
the
killer lymphocytes the t
cells and so forth also you have
eosinophils and basophils you have
neutrophils
all of these white blood cells you have
albumins and globulins which are the
the immune proteins you have antibodies
themselves
you have your digestive system your skin
your tears the mucus in your body all of
that
requires 90 essential nutrients to
produce this immune system which is not
just your killer t
cells it includes all of these tissues
and
and cells and organs of your body also
if you have
these types of problems you want to get
some of these
these hipaa filters at your workplace in
your home when you sleep you get the
ones that you plug in your car
you want to eat as much organically
grown food as possible you want to drink
filtered
waters you want to get as much chemicals
out of your diet as possible
and reduce this pressure on your immune
system if you have food allergies you
want to have a five-day rotation diet
you want to take the wonderful digestive
aid we have in american longevity called
ultimate enzyme ultimate enzyme which
has
the pepsin and the betaine hydrochloride
which will help a person digest the
proteins down into single amino acids
and it's the proteins and the allergens
such as
danders and foods and pollens and dust
that cause the
the allergies and even can initiate an
attack of asthma
thank you you're very welcome dr wallach
i first of all would like to
personally salute you for the efforts
that you're making well thank you
i um like so many other people
were vaguely aware of things you
certainly have got my attention
well good that's what it's all about i'd
like to come back just for a second on
this
the uh copper thing
copper if if a person has
those visual symptoms gray hair and that
and decides to supplement and go after
it a little bit
it's is it possible that or what is the
maximum some person can take without
i i've heard that copper can you can
over you can take too much copper
that's a great question because people
are concerned about
overdosing with vitamins and minerals
including copper
and i'll answer you two ways one in
generality and then specifically
the general answer is that if you look
at the medical profession
according to the center for disease
control harvard medical school the u.s
news and world report ralph nader sydney
wolf rand corporation
and many many other well-respected
institutions they say that doctors kill
a hundred and fifty thousand to three
hundred thousand americans each year in
hospitals alone
as a result of medical negligence
doctors injure 1.3 million americans
each year
in hospitals alone as a result of
medical negligence and doctors infect
two million americans alone in hospitals
as a result of medical negligence for a
total of three and a half million
casualties inflicted on the american
public each year in hospitals
just as a result of medical negligence
on the other side of this picture
there's not a single
person who's overdosed in vitamins and
minerals and trace minerals
including copper to the point where they
have to be hospitalized or anything bad
happen
and so when you compare the safety of
vitamins and minerals and trace minerals
including copper
compared with standard medical
procedures it's enormously safe and
that's why i'm so excited about
nutrition
and the formula and the plant-derived
minerals including copper
now to answer your question specifically
i can tell you this
if you take the plant derived copper
like you find in the form of two doses a
day
that hair color will begin to come back
it always starts at the nape of the neck
comes over the crown of the head then
down the sides of the head
and when that happens almost everybody
sees some repair
may be significant maybe total repair of
the
veins and the arteries and by repairing
the the
elastic fibers and i i'm reluctant to
give you a milligram dose because the
first thing somebody does is run out and
get
x number of milligrams of copper and in
of itself a
loan a freestanding single nutrient
you're not going to be happy with the
result
because of lack of absorbability and
there's other cofactors such as amino
acids that have to be there
for the copper to work very efficiently
including a trace a trace mineral called
molybdenum
and so i prefer to just tell you to take
the from it twice a day if you want to
speed up the process
american longevity has a great product
called ultimate selenium which has some
additional chelated copper in it
and that's the direction i'd go dr
wallach my 16 year old daughter has been
diagnosed with fibromyalgia what can you
do for her
well it's actually an easy one we
eliminated fibromyalgia in animals in
and in sheep it was called stiff lamb
disease and also in sheep
and calves and foals with your baby
horses and chickens and turkeys and any
any other animal that was raised for
meat uh the disease is uh
caused by a deficiency of three
nutrients the trace mineral selenium
vitamin e
and the sulfur-bearing amino acid
methionine and there's two things you
have to do to deal with fibromyalgia
number one
eliminate the free radicals and the
trans fatty acids that actually initiate
damage to the muscle
and cause a scarring of the muscle
tissue which is very painful even normal
muscle movement
and you can understand why they call it
stiff lamb disease if you have
fibromyalgia
first of all you eliminate fried foods
such as fried potatoes
which are you know teenagers live on
fried potatoes right so
eliminate fried potatoes fried chicken
fish shrimp fried eggs
tempura stir fry anything fried all
margarine salad dressings with oils in
them have to be eliminated
and then again the problem is perfect
because it has optimal amounts
of the trace mineral selenium in both
the plant-derived form
has optimal amounts of vitamin e and the
sulfur-bearing amino acid
methionine and it just works like a
charm
very quickly within weeks or months they
feel and they can recognize some
benefit and many people get significant
benefit very quickly
great dr wallach are baby formulas
enough for our babies when they're born
unfortunately not
our formulas that we give to dogs
whether it's kind of like
science dot dog food or the puppy or
kitten
milk replacers for puppies and kittens
you're going to raise by hand
have 40 minerals in them including
the minerals lithium chromium vanadium
and selenium
welcome primo laboratory rat pellets
contain 28 minerals including lithium
chromium vanadium and selenium
there's not a single human milk replacer
on the market
on a off the shelf of a grocery store
that has more than 12 minerals none of
them contain lithium chromium vanadium
and only two
pro soybean enfamil have selenium in
them
and it's tragic that we give our dogs 40
minerals and our rats 28 and our kids 12
or less
you can begin to see why we spent 1.2
trillion dollars
for health care last year you begin to
see why we only live to be 75.5
half of our genetic potential for
longevity 120-140
why we only rank 17th in longevity and
19th in healthiness
simply because we don't get the basic
raw materials to develop properly and
maintain repair cells from the
very beginning i'll give you a tragic
example
sudden infant death syndrome is
something everybody is familiar with
we eliminated sudden infant death
syndrome and animals back in the 1950s
because
farmers can't afford to lose two or
three or five or ten percent
of the baby animals are raising to
sudden infant death syndrome we learned
it was due to a deficiency of the trace
mineral slam causing sudden death in the
most robust the healthiest
of the baby animals in in the group or
the herd of the flock
and we eliminate it simply by giving the
pregnant mothers selenium and as soon as
the baby is born or hatched they get
selenium
and if you look at the human infant milk
replacers on the market
only two of all of them put selenium in
the formula and so if i was going to
raise a child today
on these infant milk replacers these
infant milk
formulas in a can or a bottle or a box
i would pick the two pro soybean infamil
that have selenium in them
and to stack things in favor of the
child i would still get them from the
moment they're born
a teaspoon for 20 pounds of body weight
to the problem twice a day
obviously you may not want to use the
orange juice in a new barn baby because
they can develop allergies to it
but i would still give them the
plant-derived minerals and vitamins and
amino acids
the tragic example of this is 65
this is a known fact 65 percent of all
the babies
dying of sudden infant death syndrome in
america are being fed
canned milk replacers two-thirds of the
ones who die of sudden infant syndrome
are being fed these canned infant
formulas
and i guarantee you they're being fed
the ones that don't have selenium in
them
and so uh absolutely it's important to
supplement these babies from birth
because you can't get everything you
need from your four food groups
certainly not out of these canned
formulas
great thank you dr wallach does
sleep deprivation affect our bodies much
the same as heavy exercise uh
whether it be through work or athletic
endeavors
absolutely our body requires amounts of
rest to regenerate and rebuild itself
and to repair and maintain itself
and you notice that growing children
require a lot of sleep
is because they're developing and to
perform these processes of development
repair
and maintenance we need an enormous
amount of rest and sleep deprivation can
prevent these
these healing and developing processes
you can for a short period of time
replace sleep with nutrition that's one
of the reasons why i'm
10 pounds overweight is because i eat
four or five meals a day because
i work 20 hours a day seven days a week
and i've been doing this for about 12
years now
and you can for short periods of time
maybe a week or 10 days
replace some sleep with nutrition by
eating more eating
better taking all essential nutrients as
a supplement
but eventually you're going to have to
to catch up and and sleep
otherwise you're not going to repair
completely you're not going to maintain
yourself you're not going to develop
properly
not only does this affect your physical
body your physiological functions but
also
your emotions and your ability to
tolerate stress and so forth so
certainly
sleep is an extremely important uh part
of the health picture
you probably have many more questions so
contact the person who gave you this
tape and they'll talk to you about
dr wallach's vitamins and minerals and
dr wallick's books and tapes
hey all you doctor wallach supporters
and youngevity fans out there
most of you at some point will have come
up against this nutra smart
bashing of dr wallach there are a few
articles that are published specifically
to tarnish dr wallach and his message
and i have actually written this whole
book this was a few years ago i wrote a
full-length book
in rebuttal to these vicious attacks on
dr wallach
i believe every objection that you are
going to encounter in the field
is addressed in this book it's
absolutely a great resource for you to
have as a distributor and if you do ever
have anybody coming up to you
saying i heard what you said about dr
wolik and i was going to look into some
of his vitamins but
you know i came up against this article
on the internet nutrasmart article is
probably the one they read
so it's a great deal guys i put it up
very cheap it's just
another tool in our toolbox and the
amazon link is in the description of
this video
make sure to check out our food youtube
channel called notice foods
this is 100 dr wallock approved
and the chef that is preparing the food
here and teaching you how to
follow dr wallach's food guidelines and
dr glidden's food guidelines
he's a industry professional over 22
years experience and a college diploma
to back it up
and we do have experienced cooks and
bakers as well working on content for
the youtube channel notice foods and the
instagram channel
notice foods so 100 gluten free
oil free all the stuff about burning
fats and all of the rules
that you would need to know or follow
we're here to teach it to you here
as well as give you tons of ideas for
recipes
individual dishes and meals of course in
the near future we do have a cookbook
coming out stay tuned for it
and definitely check out my newest book
fake diseases it covers all of the major
topics that come up
like birth defects blood sugar problems
bone and joint problems
cancer autoimmune problems and more and
it's on amazon for just 9.99
and the audiobook read-along version is
free here on youtube
the link for that is in the description
of this video and if you'd like to talk
to us directly you can call us
actually you can call judy she's
downriver detroit you can call from
anywhere in the u.s
canada mexico uk australia
new zealand any other country you want
to email us or send us a dm on whatever
app
that you want to contact us on instagram
is super convenient for us
and that's for any sales or product
information in those countries
or any distributor information
[Music]
you